みんなどれだけ人生のうちであったこと3回
おっと島れた札そっちもネタじゃねーぞ人生でどれだけの時間っていうね私もねだり恋
じゃなく脚です人生のうちでどれだけ購入を出して立つ本当に時間を作っている
でしょうか
小学校だけ宿題もよく忘れた c 中様式
co co o 2センサーぬーっは
あーまたとんでもないかと思いついてしまったよたち時間さえ簡単にいうとどれだけ
長い時間立ってられるかというチャレンジでございますそれぐらいの天才的な足の脚力
のもし同時になるといいですね
もう日本はセナ俺くらいの天才的な足の脚力の持ち主になると立つことぐらいはもう
余裕なんだ
朝飯前立カード15時間とかもそういうレベルでずっと立ってると思うんで今回は.な
ガイドがいいまちのぞ
みんな大変っさせてごめんたっっ秒者なるべく太ももリコーくっつけておきますツイ
口呼吸はしても良いでしょう正しい悩みな水分補給は原点の最初になりますまた販促の
恐れがありますのでもうに両手をついた状態で競技に臨んでください足
途中10度にここ90度に開いておいてくださいこれが基本的な状態ですあとトイレは
先に退いてください頻尿の方申し訳ございませんトイレに入った時点で失格ですこれ
だけ廊下で去ってなさいと言われたことか
取れないには卒業式修了式部活の変な入賞のあのな忍耐1検体が出場おめでとう
正蔵私も取れ時間
てみてたことか構造されてどれだけ長い話聞いてたことかコンビニのバイト
二しか入ったとにずっと立ってた新幹線4時間つと取って待ってたそういうの積み方
ねーがーいまぁ俺はこたつ力を作ったざまぁ蹴る技ですねもう
恩恵たですからはい
[音楽]
ブーブーに行きどっで地すこかにょんちゃん始まるわけです
あ別に暇なわけじゃないよ12時からスタートしたので
プロジェクトっていうかここで一目瞭然だと思いますよろしくお願います
[音楽]
ついなん
してる人やっともし違いきました
1時間皆さん
[音楽]
バカなんでいい誰一人で1時間たちっぱなしなのかについて動画で言ってみましょう
ん
[音楽]
年間越浦震度は頭痛と味が勝数で間接的な痛みも感じてきましたもう死にそうです助け
て下さい
なんでこんなことしてたらそう自分のためさん見せてやるぜ俺の武士道座間市
今はダメを助けてくれたみんなのたを思い出すそいつ等のためなら俺はどんな苦しい
子育てのできる
[音楽]
そう
自分のためによっ
この俺を
ここまで
動き
ここん
goo
ぷっ
うっす
me
うふふ
がんばれ
目標は声で時間を決めたことをやり通せ
男だろうーっ
かかとと膝が超絶いたいん
初音6
これあのあれです
[音楽]
やばい切手です
僕はらアート過ごしデー
2時間だっ
僕は運
このゲームをやって
2思った何の意味が
あるのかということ
おっ
goo
ああああああ
うううう
ん
me
ハーイいい
てっ
入って2時間ちょいなんでよかった
挑戦してみてね1時間棒立ちで
ん
時間を無駄にした男だないっちゃ